[Music]
what's something you learned from your
dad
that is passed through ken that you are
so excited to pass along like what's
something you still carry with you
something you carry with you well i was
talking to my dad this morning
yeah and so the easy answer to that
question is
he taught me the most valuable lesson
that any human has ever taught me
yeah um and it uh
it has been with me since i was a
seven-year-old soccer player
dang dude seven years seven years old so
i'm a little guy now imagine me at seven
i look like i was
four did you have a humongous head and
tiny little legs
uh nothing about me humongous i think
everything was a huge hit
everything everything on me is like a
running q-tip i'm just small
guy small guy there it is and so i'm
showing up to play
in a six to eight year old league or six
seven to ten something i don't know
i'm the smallest kid on the team okay
now this was back in the day this is in
the 80s
so everybody didn't get a trophy and
there was no equal plane time i'm
serious
no i'm not i remember those days i'm not
trying to old school all of a sudden
folks i'm just telling you that was my
reality come on kelly yeah right
so if you're listening to yourself you
get equal playing time in little league
if you weren't good just
you never played you sat over in the
corner of the dugout looking through the
chain link
eating big league chew and there'd be
one coach should go to the other coach
and go
should we put him in and then run up to
right field nope one inning yeah yeah
yeah this was the reality i remember so
here i am little kenny coleman
i look like i'm four i'm seven i wanna
play soccer
i really am pretty decent at it but my
coach fred cerbal
never forget his name no wound at all
nothing there at all he doesn't play me
you're like that guy in billy madison he
doesn't play me
and i don't know if this is two or three
games in the season fast forward
one day on the way home from the game
i'm in the back seat my dad's driving
just the two of us
i'm crying he notices i'm crying it's
the old conversation to the rearview
mirror oh yeah our eyes are meeting
i'm sobbing what's wrong bud i croak
through tears
something along the lines of i just want
to play or i'm not playing something
like that
he looks at me and he says hang in there
your time will come four words
your time will come now he then goes on
to say
you're small you'll eventually get a
little bit bigger a little bit faster
coach will give you a chance and you're
going to
play and you will score goals you
prophesize if you will over me
came true yeah two years later i'm the
oldest in the league i make the travel
select team i'm scoring lots of goals
life is glorious there you go cue the
john mellencamp glory days right
so that lesson stayed with me
in my 20s when i was trying to get into
politics and i got in it stayed with me
in my 30s and i don't have time to
unpack it because we got to go i'm sure
but
um even as i sit here today on the
precipice of 47
yeah about the launch
probably my most important massive book
yeah
uh an assessment other things massive
pressure
because dave's giving us a platform and
we're actually helping people
and i want to do more i want to do it
faster
your time will come and he taught me
patience
while persisting very difficult thing to
do and you
like i'm trying to put myself in so
that's like in the driver's seat of that
car
yeah i bet your dad's heart was ripped
out like look
at your son crying and thinking i can't
fix this i got a seven-year-old back
there whose world has been shattered
he wants to just want to play just wants
to play man
yeah and and for him to have those words
your time will come and um
i'm gonna i believe i'll write a parable
style book on that message one day
can i tell you the most important thing
i've ever learned my old man my dad
um man
very similar similar playing baseball
and
i've always been a big kid and so i had
an opposite thing but
i had a rough season and i was good out
in the field but i was really struggling
to play
and he said something if you can hit the
ball it will find a place in the field
for you
yeah and i remember thinking man if i
can put the time in
because i wasn't practicing i was
running around my buddies but it was a
statement of
if if if you can play yeah that's it
and it was a i i felt a sense of
the ball's in your court man yeah um
like the
the universe has smiled on you you're a
big kid
you want to put to work and i've always
had that hey i'm not i'm not getting
this job i didn't get this promotion
then i'm probably not ready for it right
i'm not there yet
and for all the dads out there for right
wrong or indifferent
and those little those little those
moments he had no idea
stay with you he had no idea how
profound that was until many years later
i told him and he was in tears
and to be honest with you there's
nothing profound there it's profound
but it's four words so speaking life
into your kids man that's what i'm
saying man
doesn't matter how it sounds mom doesn't
matter how it sounds dad
just absorb it just throw your heart out